oh hell yeah oh oh there we go we got
waveform since we got wave web we have
an mp3 forms yeah dude I'm ink is happy
through what cuz they're there all those
um side by sides of going around I just
did one that was really fun well they
have like three first the same clip
that's a mystery as to what file type
they are and it's just like experiment
they've been running to see how much
people can recognize it and how much
they care about audio quality so i can't
remember i think one of them is like a
wave one of them is an mp3 320 or
whatever and the other ones like an mp3
18 years ago Emily OH came to tell the
difference between the varying levels of
compression yeah that's sort of and
they're just sort of running that
experiment cuz they're all these music
services now and I think the big thing
with title was about how oh it's CD
quality but but like CD quality isn't
even isn't as good as like other
qualities and mp3 qualities as good a CD
quality and it's leo you know sir so
yeah well wide web or lossless what
about flack ya rehman in the house i
feel like i could tell i feel like i
won't time listen to something as a flac
file versus as like an mp3 and it felt
very different I want to record a flac
file wearing a flak jacket yeah I don't
take a lot of flack for it cuz the track
won't be very good yeah it will just be
a bad you'll just be using flack over a
really compressed beat yeah just like
it's like a beatnik ass Bongo hmm this
is like me doing spoken word poetry but
it's not really poetry it's a flag this
episode a guy stuffs is brought to you
by flak and all of its various Larry's
meetings areas meaning however flak
whatever flag means to you it brought
this episode dança steps to your door
whatever flag don't matter the cash
hopefully it brought us with it however
you have been Mau Mau din the flat
catcher
it's now Mound in the flat catcher yeah
mama on the flat catcher that sounds
like a like a weird scat band I know
it's from something I forget what it
means but I know it's from something i
just picked up you record right now
mount a flat catcher it does sound like
something like that yeah watch it be
just like a very obscure like Al Jarreau
side project I just want to hear you
yeah whatever whatever it means no open
forum for all the dank ciples out there
to find out what Mau Mau flat catcher is
yeah let us know go on the internet
we're not going to spell it out because
that would make things to me I have no
idea how it's well I don't to yes I
don't do you know cuz we're joy yeah our
don't yeah we don't even don't ask frogs
yes don't des grub welcome to day guess
tubs cultural comedy and commentary from
your wonderful host gern Denari german
airy and also dank ass stuffs also
brought to you by den cast o's brought
to you by frank s tubs flank ass rubs
spices for your next barbecue put it put
on the meat put on me fourth of July's
coming up or it's on its way or it's
already past depending on when you're
listening to this flank Frank s tubs
flank ass rubs and also jerk if you're
looking to jerk your beef just get this
caribbean jerk get it get that get the
joke that Islander flavor yeah the a
jerk via bad version mark this in the
jerk I never soldier yours in the German
her signature oh it's a movie all right
that's what I've heard about it pretty
you know I feel like the jerk is like
the granddaddy of most will ferrell
comedies and that this isn't a story as
much as just like really funny
one-liners just kind of strung together
arbitrarily with with a a man-child main
character that's just there to kind of
like give a reason why all these
ridiculous statements are coming out of
anyone's mouth I get down I can get down
sometimes because I mean it's like the
the jerk started basically with Steve
Martin's joke from his stand-up which
was always
easy for me I was born a poor black
child and that was it is the joke is
this white as white can be guys saying
that to a crowd of people with a
straight face and then just like the
joke was like yeah but let's do that for
real yeah and I'm basically odd the jerk
is like this ridiculous kind of like
structurally it's kind of is ridiculous
like i can't believe i'm using this word
for the scoop he has steve martin county
but it's basically a bildungsroman it
just this is a story of a kid with a
with you know some issue plaguing his is
psyche as a child like growing and
learning and rising and falling and
finding love and losing love and finding
love again but it's all just [ __ ]
ridiculous all right ah sounds
ridiculous oh it's just a ridiculous
it's sick redic sick redic dude hella
Ryan's today yeah Frank a Stubbs Frank
yes rose oh you know that reminds you
know not not Frank as tubs the wonderful
sponsor of the menu we were Terry a jerk
oh well Ferrell Will Ferrell you know
what I just watched what I watched the
will ferrell Kristen Wiig lifetime ass
movie oh the depth a deadly adoption how
was that the here's the thing it's
really hard to describe how it was
because it was like it's funny because I
was just laughing at okay so the trailer
for Bojack horseman season 2 dropped and
one of the little like critical bylines
is just hard to describe purchases I'm
not I'm not [ __ ] you it's like was
it posed in a way that like it was
supposed to be funny or was it just kind
of using it it was thrown out there in a
way that was supposed to be funny
because like the trailer showing just
how whacked out and silly everything is
ok but just kind of hold it's the
letters it's like well with the show
like Bojack horseman what do you like
how do you how do you market it outside
for saying it's hard to describe it it's
like one thing was like bowtie horseman
is is hilarious and then the other two
were like heart subscribe and like
nothing you've seen before so I was like
one person said oh it's funny and then
it's like
we can't find other people saying this
is funny so let's just go with what
everyone else is saying and that this
show is weird beyond weird beyond any
measure weird beyond all measure yes I
watched the deadly adoption deadly
adoption and so I look up the vle Grover
the thing is like I had this thought
part way through the film or the TV
movie pneumatic experience but they like
a deadly adoption is like I'm sitting
there to my something this is pretty bad
but it's not that bad but like what is
ya know it occupies this weird
inexplicable space because like
everybody's everybody has basically said
this about lifetime now that lifetimes
recent output has been like very just
not piss self-parody but self-aware so
it's like it occupies this weird space
now where they're not trying to be like
oh this is no listen this is grabber
it's like we get it we're we're a
lifetime we understand what we are and
here's the boot like so you know what's
gonna happen but there's something about
the fact that the movies themselves also
acknowledge that you know what's going
to happen that makes them a little
easier to kind of embrace cuz it's like
it's it's still a lifetime movie but for
a lifetime movie there's some
surprisingly good moments Lee so it's
really weird is this a spoof or not no
it's no like they play it straight like
will ferrell and kristen wiig play it
straight they're very earnest are they
playing it straight like they like they
play dumb it's not the spoils of Babel
it's not it's not supposed bet okay so
that's interesting to me yeah I don't
know how to describe describe it quite
because yeah it's not self-parody again
it's like lifetime seems to have found
this weird niche where they've
acknowledged just what how people
perceive them and what their movies are
generally like you know these sort of
pulp dramas and just sort of have
embraced that thing so and so they just
cast to comedic actors and still a
self-indulgent pulp drama yeah
yeah without playing to self-indulge on
polk drama as a comedy but that my brain
is kind of breaking I think I have to
see this yeah it was fun Legos it was
you know it's it's a lifetime movie but
but not a lifetime movies like a
lifetime movie like yeah it kind of
breaks your head to try and describe it
we had no Will Ferrell and Kristen where
you're good like and no there's all
sorts of like their daughter has some
kind of diabetes and then like their
other kid dies because like Kristen
Wiig's who's out on the rotting dock at
their house and she fell over the edge
because she was out on the rotting dock
and now he blames himself their childish
like it's you know it's very life timing
Wow and then more [ __ ] ensues but you
know and Jessica lounges who like when
she has to go all crazy and [ __ ] like
yeah pretty pretty good flux like it's
weird she goes yeah so I telly my brain
is breaking it's like it's something you
enjoy in spite of itself but also not in
spite of itself because it understands
too and it doesn't try to get to wacky
with it it's not the guy who's like no
no I know guys right dad like it just is
like I know i'ma still be me though you
know it's weird but yeah I was
interested in was some welfare alas
adoption shoot it's because of the
spoils of Babylon there's some other
spoils of the spoils before dying who
spoils before dying three-part
miniseries yeah so I FC is coming out
with another Eric jonrosh masterpiece I
was so excited I mean spoils of Babylon
I was so tickled by like yeah I still
got to finish that i started i never got
back to finishing the spoils of Babylon
as well as a Babylon for the uninitiated
is a like a miniseries that was on IFC
but made by funnier guy starting yes
it's like will ferrell Adam McKay yeah I
mean helming yet
like a parody of like 70s potboiler
miniseries yes in describe any the
closest thing that I've seen it reminded
me of was the carpetbaggers if anyone's
ever seen that okay okay yeah maybe a
brief summary for the folks playing line
okay I mean so it's like just kind of
like this story of you know the the fam
the history of this guy it is extremely
the toby mcwire place like this
changeling guy who's who doesn't know
where he comes from he's just like a use
a kid with amnesia that gets found by
the spoils I think oh this somehow
garment bag Oh Toby well by the way toby
mcwire was in the carpetbagger well I'm
no it wasn't so it's like they're there
are similar themes to the carpetbaggers
if you've ever seen it which I doubt
anyone has ever seen depart with actors
cuz it's in nope nobody who is under
double my age as seen the carpetbaggers
you you've seen too much they're gonna
hunt you down Obama's Obama's anti the
carpetbaggers force is going to come out
of the woodwork in and take me the
Guantanamo because I know too much you
seem too much I'm the Eric Snowden of
the carpetbaggers dude that needs to be
your title forever hey old is the air
yes Edward so died were Derek Snowden
did not about to say it too and that was
like MIT good right he's super wrong
Edward Snowden he doesn't have a first
name anymore if Oliver Stone is to be
believed he's just Snowden now no Daisy
snow dizzle snow for days look uh yeah
no it's a sort of like epic like the
rise and fall of a family a family
Empire coming up from nothing and then
like injury just seen betrayal romance
forbidden love extraneous [ __ ] yeah
like and it's I don't know like I saw
spoils of Babylon I was just so tickling
as its as it continues it gets more and
more bizarre and more more off the rails
and there's a whole light because it
covers like every major like time period
and event
one point he's in World War two and
they're one point he's like a beatnik
like he's doing drugs beat poetry yeah
there's like this whole thought there's
this whole like hard bop like segment
we're just like this the whole episode
most of it's just this one long bondage
/ tobey maguire doing a weird parody
beat poem but even a weird parity people
was kind of a great yeah thing like it
is kind of cool and kind of well done in
like it feels very authentic yeah it's
like it's like someone research actual
beat poetry to make this yeah it's like
your signal you're like oh it's funny
he's doing V poetry but then you
actually kind of get into it and it just
keeps going and you're like oh it feels
like we good it feels like it's half
bizarre but he's half saying like
salient points about like the subculture
of Greenwich Village and the rise of
heroin Charlie Parker due to do haha so
great and like I mean an address in
peace bird ah just like I just admire
like that's like you know there are a
lot of things that appealed to me in
comedy but that that kind of thing is
sort of my kind of comedy because it's
it's like absurd and silly and things
just kind of happened because like
certain stuff is referential and then
other things are very you know justjust
piece of Tareq and kind of arbitrary but
in an arbitrary with it still feels kind
of earned yeah it's like there's there's
randomly terrible continuity and
definitely you know like some of the
things characters say yeah I don't know
I just loved I loved it so much and all
the while and all the while will ferrell
it is at the beginning and at the end of
every segment of the miniseries playing
dislike ridiculous overblown like Leigh
fortson well or SIA guy named Eric
jonrosh who very clearly just like went
way to drunken self indulgent with
making this miniseries and that's why
it's not just a lonely the entire cast
yeah and he's getting increasingly drunk
as he's sitting in runner on talking
about talking about the making of the
spoils of Babylon yeah
somebody so like midway through it he's
slurring the title so much it's just
like this boils about this boils the
bottle now oh I want to watch it again I
watched it I gotta watch it through I
have to finish it have to be I've to
begin it I have to middle it and I have
to end it dude get your ass on that I do
a must cuz ya now must I must I must
increase our bust get arrested by the
note officers cuz ya now there's a few
as new income spoils before dying which
is like a this is not apparently also
nerve John Ross doing it jabs his epic
tale of a pianist turned detective
investigating a murder in the nineteen
fifties underground jazz scene oh yeah
haha gasps I'm so down oh and who's the
start cuz I cuz I god is great huh
spoils this is the the thrilling part
where I google thing yes um hold on to
your butts google time hold on to your
butts we got to come up with a song for
google time google time google time this
song sucks but it's google time I like
it bye we just got throw something like
lazily playing a thumb piano over that
Michael Tennant Williams who is that man
Michael Kenneth Williams you've seen him
his stuff before well but i'll refresh
you I don't see things dude you should
see a thing I have never seen a single
thing in my life there's some pretty
cool a stick since I don't believe
usually gone baby gone gone baby gone
not the david ranta movies but the casey
affleck film oh is it funny just like is
it 12 you're slightly using bloggers
which year is he the robot cop is the
purge anarchy oh I think he was on I do
not think it was the robot cop in 12
years a slave whew what's he play you're
wrong wrong I don't recall the robot cop
in 12 years a slave it's not a wire the
wire yeah he's on the wire that's what
the wire everybody everybody
be freaking out because he was on why on
that but why my coat and we have to have
like an actual song that plays under all
of google time yeah while we here I'll
show you his likeness it's going to be
an offbeat version of the Jeopardy like
weightings oh oh my god is he oh ma he
might be everybody loves Omar is he Omar
from the wire he looks you might be Omar
from the wire I never watched the wire
I've never watch the wire either but
everyone goes over your words there's
the part where Omar is coming there's
the part where Omar is in the wire and
is everyone's favorite here everyone
loves Omar Omar hair advice it's right
Oh we'll see inherent sure we'll see
device
yeah he was all mine I was gonna
harmonize with you
go saints oh sorry kind of crazy just so
hands yeah Michael Kenneth Williams is
in it my Rudolph is in it Maya Rudolph
yeah Will Ferrell is yeah Eric jonrosh
yeah haley joel osment is back and
better than ever hey I mean I seen as
well as Babylon I was like wow like cuz
i had seen him in a while he's really
funny I I did not get to the part where
Haley Joel Osment scared crew shows up
tell us I will just wait family yes
tonight's episode is not even about the
spoils of Babylon oh I was we're excited
for the spoils of Babylon we're gonna
start off this episode four things were
excited for I'm aside for Bojack
horseman season two and i'm excited for
the spoils before dying I'm excited been
spoiled before god I'm excited for
boating airport I'm excited to finish
the spoils of Babylon I'm excited too
probably rewatch them some point I just
finished finished the season of Game of
Thrones and then I finished the season
of mad men now I have his last seven
episodes please darling people who are
like lets players but for TV because
there's a lot of TV out there that I
need to watch and it would be cool it
would be cool if like if I had to watch
that much TV it would be cool to get
paid for it because it seems like wood
after what people keep on saying oh you
have to watch this you have to watch
that it feels like watching TV is now a
job that everyone has but everyone's not
doing enough work at well yeah cuz
there's so many shows that are so
purportedly great it's like how do I do
damn you knew gilded age of television
yeah damn you to heck all right I mean a
strong winds everything I could do to
start jumping on a couple me says every
but I did like oh I love this [ __ ] out
of madmen I gotta watch Mad Men Batman's
[ __ ] I gotta watch the maddest of man
I think you would dig it I think that
would do you want dig I'm a madman I'm a
white guy house I would love that then
probably hey the 60s happened on that
mentally yeah um yeah no mmmm emmons
awesome i just finished first they're
doing a breaking bad where it's like
season 7
and 7b so granted all that has already
aired yeah but it's all gonna watch the
second there are no more bad men they're
all calm now and we're all chill second
half so I can watch them all sale he
respected but yes they have it we good
then I finished the season of Game of
Thrones which was also good but I won't
spoil that like it's plugged me I'm
sorry it's alright it actually was ok
because we spoiled it for you the
internet because the Internet is weird
thing now where it's like it's looping
back around where people are like okay I
want to post I have to post but I don't
want to spoil it so I'm gonna put like
the the kitty gloves on to such a degree
that now it's kind of obvious what I'm
talking about even though I'm really
trying to dance around it and like in
trying to dance around it i'm pretty
much just saying it so like well yeah
but it was great it was okay because
like the thing that was spoiled i wasn't
expecting the moment at all so it was
still a punt okay you knew was coming
but you didn't know when yeah when I was
watching him tonight I kind of got
caught up in it so i forgot to think
about it you know so you know that's a
thing begin no television is a heart
keep up with you admire those who can do
it i do a mediocre job at best I gotta
say you know it's a good thing that
movie sucked so much yes because it's
like oh now I can just focus on TV and I
don't have to don't have to bother with
most movies its duty dude who'd like
things are so weird now because like
people flock like you know a lot of the
movies not that all big movies are bad
but like people flock to you know it's
easy for a big loud noisy dumb movie to
make a bajillion dollars and people
freak out about you know pretty pretty
simple stuff you know like people freak
out over blockbuster tentpole action
movies and stuff like this oh my gosh
cr7 learn about you know which you know
however fun those my beef don't seem
like they're particularly you know
groundbreaking in any way I mean they
probably like to severe damage to the
actual ground and the course of life
driving so recklessly over them well I
ok magnificent maybe they are torn up
naturally groundbreaking like san
andreas literally broke lots of great
yeah CGI brown yeah not real where well
because that would cause out costume all
of the city infrastructure but like at
the same time people freak out about
arguably not overly qualitative in some
respect movies and people then freaked
out about really great shows and it's
weird like cuz oftentimes it's the same
people it's like the same people look
forward to big loud noisy thing at the
movie theater but home early college is
Joe is so good and it's like really it's
also quality writing yeah I wonder if
it's like we're kind of distilling what
people want out of a movie person what
they want out of TV and it's like people
have become kind of like almost like
bifurcated sense where it's like all of
them if I want something that's going to
be like mine break mind-bending or
really emotionally gripping or really
intellectually stimulating an intimate
and and really get at me at a personal
smart level I'm going to watch it in the
comfort of my own home alone with you no
just me in my own domain and and be
connected to the show and with a lot of
time to let things develop whereas if
I'm going into a movie theater why I'm
in a dark room with strangers with this
plan of strangers and you know I'm only
going to be there for two hours just you
know make sure blow up and just give me
and cuz you know I have this enormous
screening from me and I'm with people
I'm not connecting to you because it's a
roomful stranger so you show me a lot of
cool [ __ ] blowing up maybe that's
secretly what people wanted out of TV
serials versus what they wanted out of
movies this whole time and it's now just
like we're kind of drifting into that
world I feel like you can make an
argument are made for direction already
just a matter just kind of like
cultural factors and different trends
that have kind of like sprung up between
TV and movies well I almost think that
now it's like for what we demand of
entertainment now in any regard this
seems like TV has a better has the means
to do what people are demanding in a
better way because think about it like
every movie that does marginally okay
everyone's like sequel and then it's
like well [ __ ] we told a complete story
what do we do now and it's it's like on
tv minions movie to the minions their
own movie the movie for the menus hello
I mean I almost prefer that at least two
cuz I pickable meat-free yeah kind of
cuz at least is changing the focus now
it's like you know let's let's I don't
explain to me it's like the reason why
Shrek was such a smash hit but no one
thinks highly of like shrek three or
shrek four is like Shrek's art as a
human being or as a character was
completed shrek one yeah exactly he was
grumpy man who was misanthropic and
didn't want to connect to anybody and
then he learns to be vulnerable and open
himself up for love yeah and then that's
it the story is done now so it's like
now he's a real boy and now he's a real
boy so it's like pretty more Shrek
movies just like what like what's there
what to do what he's done these needs yo
cash his check he's grown as it as a
coger yeah yeah one of his life it's
over I feel like TV can solve a lot of
problems because it's also like now we
expect these franchise movies so it's
like you have to have you have to have
like a complete story for two hours you
have to have some kind of art but you
can't have too much of an arc because
you know there's got to be something to
chew on next time we couldn't have to
have some intelligence and some movies
managed to put a lot of the big
blockbuster stuff with like okay here
are some kind of neat ideas and a lot of
cool [ __ ] around them whereas I feel
like TV now can be like we can have our
great dialogue in our character
development and we can have full [ __ ]
and we can keep this going for a long
time so that the people who are attached
to these characters can check in with
them over
time you know so it's like I feel like
in the current environment it's harder
to keep movie franchise going than it is
to just flesh out a story over a few ctp
yeah because especially now that we've
embraced the miniseries at least in
America it's like you can basically do
anthology series yeah it's like you can
give your movie breathing room now you
know I'm concerned I was like what the
what this is gonna do for the landscape
from movies like like for instance ex
machina ex machina was done you know
it's like there's yeah you're not gonna
have an ex machina to this is hard shell
it out in New York ya know it's like X
Martha note had a beginning a middle and
ended the whole story you know the whole
parable in the whole table of ex machina
was done in those two however many hours
her had a beginning middle and end and
it was done it said what need to say
yeah so it's like if the whole focus of
of hope you're gonna make a movie you
have to you know be willing to make five
movies it's just I don't you know I
don't know what that's going to do for
people who want to make something like
an ex machina or her or I know any
number of like great movies we see that
are just nice and self-contained you
know they're finished what they're done
yeah I mean I feel like they'll still
get made I feel like it it'll probably
continue with the way it is now where
it's like they'll get made it'll just be
you know perhaps not as many as should
get paid for get mail because now it's
like it was until ranch eyes least I was
until there's another I mean if what
we're looking at with with the big
tentpole Hollywood status is just like
you know another economic bubble bubbles
always burst yeah now that well and
that's the way this is what this is what
Karl Marx called the crises of
overproduction Oh Chaz yeah well this
summer is heavily like this is the most
bloated suffering long time this for
giant we've announced another spider-man
reboot hey any sounds really good i like
i like spider-man
I'm spider-man with my boy like
Spiderman was my favorite superhero I
grew up with those Sam Raimi movies
let's not do that again Leslie's let's I
was down for the whole like you know we
have to have spider-man again what's
introduced in another movie and just
have him already be a thing I'm just
looking it's like people were like oh
man I can't the spider man i can't wait
for expire in to be in the avengers i'm
just thinking the whole hog there's
always like 19 people for the main
character in The Avengers like I can get
down with that because it's like you
know any time you have a universe full
of superheroes like you want to create
combination that's not a problem to me
it's like I get what someone said I want
to see spider-man the Avengers I want to
see Wolverine in the Avengers because
it's like yeah you know I get it you
rotate in a different character and it
seems like especially with how age of
ultron went they're gonna rotate
something okay so it's not just gonna be
like they're stacking on the new
character every week with every new
avengers movie yeah cuz I like the next
Avengers gonna feature the main cast of
The Avengers already plus Scarlet Witch
plus crit clicks over plus ant-man plus
Doctor Strange plus black panther yeah
it's like I don't know what what's name
or yeah anymore I don't know why any
more is never gonna go never was this
the thing about Marvel is you never know
because Marv name wars never gonna get
movie never has won the rights were like
weirdly tied up with universe I think
they still are no it's also like WB has
already got Aquaman and the cannon name
or isn't even on the slate for Marvel
everybody want them on girl I know so
hopefully there will be a giant economic
collapse in the in the temple movie
market before that's possible well
here's the thing man my dream may my
dream is for the bottom to fall out of
Marvel before they get to do the
Avengers 3 that's what well no maybe
before the event for free or at least 3a
I want oh that's right this is a tour
it's a tour Oh what
is even more Marvel's interesting beasts
to me because you know I feel like a
weirdo because I'm sort of like a
daywalker because you know I I flux
between the two worlds it's like I can
get down at a bed of summer popcorn
movie like you know for especially for
the real reject stuff you know I have
seen a lot of the big tent full things
and you know some of them are tough to
sit through and others are fun at least
one there was the worst one to sit
through oh man oh you can look go okay
feel like I got to get a new example but
hangover 3 was 00 hangover 3 was and i
think that was closer to the summer time
to that was like a big like all it's
doing over trilogy and I was like this
didn't need to be a franchise should
have never been a trilogy yeah and you
don't understand comedy and this is like
I was that was one of the ones that
actually made me angry watching that
wasn't the whatever type of longer
sequel made you just say it's two hours
it 50 got it so run over da I didn't
even see I admit I didn't even I haven't
seen transformers movie since careful if
20 yeah I have that gone funny but uh I
mean that's the thing about tempo movies
too is like I do there's a reason we all
bag on Transformers films because they
think they're more important than they
actually are yeah you know but but
somehow they still make a [ __ ] ton of
money and like you know it's like but in
Reverse loves it it's not avert your
eyes this you kinda can't ignore the
fact that these these still make all the
money they do and I um I don't get it
now i got like took us transformers the
first one like I had fun it's fun like
it's you know it's not it's not
intelligent or newark or anything like
that but you know fer fer bigtime movie
all right I had a good time it was fine
you know the second one was like huh I
get it now we're gonna go way too long
and way too serious way to like you know
send
the series seems to have sort of gone
off the rails from there you know and
now you get transformers 4 which is
nearly three hours long and this is like
oh someone got to tell you know brother
I think you need a no man just just a
rain your [ __ ] in but like and that's
where like he did pain and gain and
paying a game I enjoyed because that
movie for once from michael bay wasn't
taking itself so seriously like putting
all this fake gravitas and everything
yeah it's like that movie you know say
what you will about it and then whether
or not it's disingenuous but it was
still a more like it had a rhythm he got
different writers and it was like snappy
and it was having a good time it wasn't
taking itself too seriously it's so kind
of smirky but you know it was a step
above a lot of the recent think their
teeth then we know it's like a I can
appreciate you know a big summer popcorn
movie and then I can go out you know a
lot of things I'm I'm festively
interested in are you know the sort of
weirder things are just the smaller
things you know it's like I like weird
little arthouse movies or any movies and
stuff like that are just the things that
aren't the main thing every weekend are
usually what i find myself interested in
so you know i occupy a weird space
because it's like I get why giant temple
movies are not necessarily a good thing
but I don't think they're bad inherently
is we have too many of them and it's
like I look at somebody like Marvel it's
like you have your Michael Bay and your
your your you know you have these
Expendables movies and stuff like that I
look around the landscape and if
everybody was doing stuff it's like I'm
okay with parts of Marvel because they
do seem to have a plan they do seem to
at least be interested in revitalizing
some sort of properties that aren't you
know just spider-man and just you know
Captain America it's like oh we're doing
ant-man that's kind of strange out we're
doing guardians the galaxy that's kind
of strange oh we're gonna do black pants
are cool like you know it's business
hour but I haven't been following an
idiot
man press really but I'm just wondering
how are they going to handle the fact
that life in the comic books I
characterize like a really terrible
domestic abuse record ah ah like the
main we're not the main thing but like
my furs is they kind of gloss over the
fact that like in the comic books Tony
Stark is like a crippled alcoholic yeah
well they yeah that's all this so it's
like how did like what do they do about
the bed that like I think Hank him into
comics's he's got like a really bad
domestic abuse record is that the
character his name was at least the
whoever Paul Rudd is playing like Steve
something oh yeah soo Scott's office
yeah so I don't know I oh that's right i
don't like a different man maybe it's
maybe a what's uh come on Hank Pym is is
Michael Douglas why so it's like a torch
pass what yeah that's crazy oh damn this
screen plans with a lot of writers oh
that's a good sign well I get it there
so because they probably took that
script and then reworked it oh yeah
those guys were right yeah yeah which I
mean that's legitimately a bummer to me
but some of the really word I've heard
of ant-man is that it at least you know
kind of separates itself from the
general Marvel formula you could call it
but you know it's like I think I get
what Marvel does and I get why they do
it it's like they're transcribing a
comic book universe to a visual medium
so it's like as much as it's convenient
and it completely allows the machine to
feed money in and out of itself so I can
get it's like you have Thor comics and
Iron Man comics and spider-man comics
and all these comics and then they're
also Avengers comics where they come
together and it's like translating that
into film is something that I do think
is neat its place among a million other
things is problematic but just that that
concept in and of itself it's kind of
cool like I get you grow up loving comic
books now you can see them come to life
in much the way that medium operates is
me to me so I don't think it's
inherently a
that thing it's almost in a way kind of
like taking us back to the days of the
cereal in a weird way yeah and so you
know for them it's like it's there
around all the time and so I get why
they make money because they're always
you know raising stakes navin characters
to pull from and I think that Marvel is
at least decent because you know they
have these big things but then it also
be like nobody knows what guardians of
the galaxy is outside the comic book
community but let's try that anyway
let's just bring that out and you know
see what we can do with that you know
we'll get this weird throw my guy to
direct it and you know maybe even hire a
woman to work on the script but a novel
idea crazy yeah and so like you know
again there are certainly troublesome
things about just big tentpole superhero
movies in general and they're there
we're sure numerous pneus yeah but you
know it's weird because we have you know
everything gets a franchising everything
continues it repeats and stuff like that
and I think I may be wrong but I think
after Avengers 3 whatever infinity wars
is going to be I think that next phase
will be a shift I think the whole point
is like we have this iteration of the
Avengers until infinity ward's and then
we're going to change either the lineup
or we're not going to do Avengers for a
while we're gonna do other characters I
think after infinity works is finished
with you going to do is because Marvel
is under distance oh but I've infinity
war spinners they're going to be done
with the three new Star Wars movies so
um so Disney is going to take the Marvel
and Star Wars money and just buy all
human life yes by planet Earth yeah rum
the earth yeah I mean didn't it's this
is a weird and then we're all going to
work at the disney mines disney's a
weird machine man because Disney it's
like it's it's scary and insidious that
they own pretty much everything that
makes money but they are smart like it's
weird it's like
but we talked a mile about inside out
and like I think inside out is great you
know and that's granted that's Pixar but
you know it's like I've liked a lot of
Disney's recent movies not like what
Marvel doesn't seem to have a smart
approach to things so I'm like your kind
of evil but also yes there's a lot like
this is actually kind of good like who I
like this and you know that's you know I
but yeah it's it's it's it's weird
because when you look at something like
dress world and you have that opposite
side of the spectrum because you have
like these vendors movies that come out
constantly you get you know at least one
or two Marvel movies every year and that
kind of creates an empire more than you
look at Jurassic world what's broken
like rude to goolies records and part of
why that is is be a part of that success
is tied into the fact that Jurassic Park
has been gone for so long you know so
it's like you have a weird double sided
coin of evidence for stuff I wonder if
we're going to find out that there is
kind of like on absence there's actually
like a absence makes the heart grow
fonder of effect where it's like we're
going to see kind of like a slowed or
some kind of diminishing returns with
Marvel but like when with the franchise
comes back that hasn't been really
approached in a while it's seif is gonna
start like making a bigger splash yeah I
Seattle I've heard the argument a few
times where it's like a superhero movies
that bubble is gonna burst people are
gonna lose interest and on the one hand
i can see definitely that could be a
thing in a you know there will always be
super if it's the boom you know that
they're so prevalent my first but on the
other hand I almost wonder the sense
there's so many characters are so many
franchises I am wonder if that whatever
happened because you can just switch you
can just feel like what people are tired
of this guy well we haven't seen that
guy in a while will do him like you know
and then you know then the Machine never
stops I don't know it's weird it's like
another talking about Jurassic Park
doing viewing another Jurassic world and
I'm like
or I I assume there because it's broken
all of the records and I'm like how how
like it's the same problem with the
original Jurassic Park it's like how do
you the whole point is like this was the
time it didn't work how are you gonna do
another movie click and I'm what they're
gonna do is the problem isn't that they
genetically spliced hybrid vents or they
denied displays the hybrid park and just
like the theme park itself is going to
come to life like the volcano in lava
yeah from the beginning have the inside
out is going to just launch dinosaurs at
people this is like the absence makes
the heart grow fonder like that
definitely has something to do with
Jurassic Park jurassic world success you
know partly because Jurassic Park free
to do so well slit some time off and
jurassic park three else didn't have as
many things blog for it doesn't seem
like um it had william h makes william h
macy I yeah I am fan but I don't think
blame h macy is gonna gonna put butts in
seats among the young crowd you want or
go he's great i love shameless shameless
didn't exist back then yeah but he now
written i don't think yeah but like you
know i don't think that movie would have
done dresden world wouldn't have been as
successful if it came out two years
later no it's because it's been of 10
years or whatever that it's like who are
going so we're not here to talk about
shredders world know or not but yeah i
don't know it's just TV movies yeah I
feel like TV has the ability it's like
you get all the benefits of a franchise
without the truncated writing or
franchise but you can't explore an idea
you can explore arts you can be tan
gentle as long as you're paying off at
least a certain amount of thing so I
feel like that's why TV I guess there's
not there's not necessarily a pressure
to keep on topping yourself did for the
sake of topping yourself a TV with TV
it's not you know the push is more to
like well what just just what will come
next net naturally and logically yeah
well you also don't pay for the same way
so there's less incentive
like how do we get people to spend $15
two seasons like yeah it's like if you
and if it's every week and you know then
free here and it's on a schedule it's
like people can latch onto that but I
feel like into playing again you can
have your cake and eat it too in the
sense you can watch something really
cool that also has some legit ideas it's
legit either you know philosophy or
character study or whatever you can have
your breaking bad where it's like a
crazed you should pretty much like [ __ ]
getting real is pretty much the mode
this show exists in but also this is
actually pretty interesting and you know
it's it's you know I can sink my teeth
into it sort of explore its ideas as
well as shit's getting real constantly
you know where's with movies barring you
know the one in a few that comes along
where it's like oh this is really smart
and really fun you could get both of
those more frequently lucky i think this
because of that longer form you know
it's hard to develop hey things off in
two hours if that's not the focus yeah
so uh TV movies interesting on them I
think this is this'll be if it's like an
ongoing topic as you as time warp and
chain as we just kind of watch where
this goes in the world yep so uh so we
get into it so let's get into it let's
let's get let's get the into it what's
good love let's get low let's become
alone we're here today talk to you guys
about this group thing got look big
olympic thing Bruce booth you really big
really big scoop rebooted big living
really big soup we had we had somewhat
proffered a different alone project in a
in a proto dank episode Frodo jank back
down yeah better the sound close I think
we only got part one of that out before
they were like you can't upload no more
yeah you got it you gotta pay for this
[ __ ] yeah this stuff forgive brush the
mouth with the potty and blue
hmm nope coming out of your mouth just
all of the time all it's here I mean how
many times have we gone who killed
tangents with you Oh Costigan jokes it
was yeah there was my Chang so history
yeah we had a poop we had a we lot of
food yeah we had a pre it sir that's my
favorite camera crew boo boo boo boo me
that's exactly to go we bought a zoo oh
thats a dude sorry I'm sorry I've seen
the Martian trailer like billion times
now yeah and like it looks awesome but
but I feel like this son I feel really
horrible saying this about somebody but
like I keep seeing that directed by
ridley scott I'm like oh I don't know if
I'm ready to trust you again yeah I
don't know already trust you again with
space man like I was gonna end in tears
well no hopefully like like we had gone
with like we had discussed before this
time to my knowledge the Martian has no
Dean little off prints on it that's good
again yeah dude my question I guess the
Martian the Martian will be our tell
like who's fault was Prometheus was a
Damon Lindelof fault or was it Ridley
Scott's fault I got imagine it's both
their faults because just like Ridley
Scott doesn't seem like if Ridley Scott
wants to change something he probably
can especially since alien you know even
though it was like oh we're just saw
universe and it's also Exodus gods and
Kings wasn't well received and that had
Norma was Robin Hood and Nora was like
the next two days nor was like oh god
I'm food I've forgotten about all these
yeah I haven't seen a Ridley Scott movie
in a while wore a blue my god this is
great like and you know were these
maybes are just the time go back to
working on them fondly cutting blade
over no no no they don't everything
never know ok yeah those like you know
Exodus gods and Kings the count sorry I
think you're home with a que hora maybe
I heard I heard the director's cut i
think is really good and that theatrical
cut is not easy sorry what oh well okay
you gotta get back on top I will stop
hustling and flowing and slowly hustle
and bro huh dude you know that was a
frat party somewhere oh no that's Umbria
with with DJ Aukerman the deeds Scott
ocker no I just think of like it's a DJ
but then it's just like some white guy
named yeah DJ Stanley with its stem
stands pretty chilly so alone alone is
not long the halloween haunt it's an
immersive art experience in is an
exploration of human emotion and things
like loneliness and stuff here and
isolation so the origins is that it was
sort by to sort of i like to calarts
grads in will have like design jobs we
decided to create their own answer to
you know a haunted houses where instead
of like clowns come at you with
chainsaws in dark corridor it's our
dudes waterboarding the dudes calling
you a [ __ ] really loud yeah it's you
experiencing you know being in a dark
silent room with something that is
strange that you don't know if it's
human or safer trustworthy or not yeah
it's it's it's you know it's slightly
it's more artistic more cerebral than a
lot of the haunts that are you know is
so they be its extreme in the sense like
you you go in you sign a waiver you know
it's like people can touch you it'll be
a very you know before personal few
rounds they're not going to cup your
testicles well sorry eric is another
erica's in the booth making gestures
rude gesture lewd and crude and ghost
walking and goes well keep that's one of
these days we will describe to you how
ghosts walk yeah it's called the ghost
walk will do in animatics
yeah wait I know so it's like it's kind
of like a friend of mine described it as
like being in the David Lynch movie and
that was I didn't get that vibe from
going through this most recent round
yeah as I went through the 2014 1 I did
yeah I didn't I didn't make the first
show this is they got this started on a
Kickstarter um and they did their first
year I think I didn't actually have that
bad that was before my extreme haunting
dance and I'm not even that extreme but
excuse and from what I heard the first
one was cool it's like you were in the
basement of this building and it was
just you and a flashlight and you know
various things I've heard it was a
little more black Audi the first year
but i don't i don't really know the
second year well i got is a black guy
was a hotbed is very like aggressive and
has kind of a very sexual way of kind of
bringing right yeah i mean i get the
system blackout is more aggressive and
more i guess more ugly you know it's
more imposing and formidable it's like
you their whole thing is you know they
want to kind of the other thing is
intimidating it's like you're scared to
go into black out because you know it's
like they're gonna put a bag on your
head and like dump water on you and then
you know force you to dig around in from
it or something like that they fun than
what you know it's gonna make you
uncomfortable it's you know they're
naked people hmm stuff like god no well
you know that was there was a room I got
the sense that at least the shows I've
heard about our made to play on
different fears and discomforts um you
know usually more aggressive in nature
his blackout seems to be people people
kind of talk about making it through in
a way that sounds like it's very extreme
and very sort of like it's gonna push
your limits and alone is a little
different that I mean it might push your
limits but in a different way they're
not interested in you know in jumping
out and and you know tackling you or are
you scaring you that way it's more about
mean your head yeah it's about getting
under your skin and getting in your head
and playing with your mind m
you know like they say in their
literature and stuff like that it's
about exploring things like fear of
loneliness and isolation and you know
the dark you know stuff like that so the
second year from what everyone told me
is sort of where they found their
they're more sure footing and they came
up with this whole sort of vague
storyline about what they called the
enola foundation which is like this new
way new agey spiritual sort of cult
thing and all their you know they always
have a voice that all the emails and all
the literature is written in and so
Enola was very sort of warm and very
nola loves you you know it's all matters
is the same and it's just all particles
by rating in a different rate you know
we will come together as one and that
was the sort of theme they wrote the
October show which was the 1i wound up
at I didn't find up with some of the
earlier ones because they were doing
this whole ramp up thing up to dear
October half like they did scare away
which is a trade show for people who
make him work them out of the halloween
haunted history in the LA area where
they did an exhibition that basically
they had a mini a miniature version of
what they do like in the face of the
scare away yeah don't people did
different write-ups on and that was you
know in that in the vein of the whole
like in nola body storyline yeah um and
then you know I think they had one other
thing I heard about and they had their
October show which was like the main you
know the centerpiece at the table and
then after that you know there was this
calving her hunt in January in January
that we did this sort of wrapped up that
story because it's not always going to
be a Noah foundation yeah the enola
foundation seems like as a storyline
thing is not in the picture this new one
doesn't even have like a storyline or an
overarching like broader narrative
surround it's just as a yeah as a team
and I mean the thing about a loan is
like the first year I went which is 2014
when we went to that show you know it's
like you do walk through a loan you were
on your own it's too snowy one's life is
fun no flat yeah no no flashlight you're
not allowed to bring in any sort of
light emitting device or recorder you
know they're they're very strict about
that and for good read and they brought
it like when we went they brought us in
five at a time and thus we were all sort
of lined up doing this
breathing exercise like we started the
experience together and pretty soon each
one of us was individually abducted you
know and then you're going through a
hole you don't half hour forty minute
experience by yourself you know and it's
just you not knowing what room is gonna
be next and you are sometimes crawling
through things you know sometimes you're
in the dark sometimes they're your ear
somebody put a bag over my head made me
run at one point like its intent they
they're good at playing on different
senses and different fears and some of
it the best friend is some of the summit
up was like the alone I went to an
October was like it was like parts
creepy and unsettling parts scary and
then other parts were kind of touching
and beautiful and very soothing in a way
so it's just a very different and a very
strange experience and in a way that
really brought you into the room because
it was like it was not what you expected
but not just because they're surprising
you a stuff it was like also just the
tone and the sort of mood of the place
was different than expected you know it
wasn't it managed to be scary without
being like row Ashley aggressive or
carnival like which was just a nice
change of pace you know because I can
get down with with a lot of different
things this was just really cool and
sort of you know the RDR side the more
cerebral side the more you know again it
plays on your mind and it gets under
your skin more than just you know being
afraid of where the next pop is gonna
come up yeah and so they're they're
doing you know they're doing their news
show this year and it seems like each
year they get a little more assured in
the forum because this year there are
four distinct parts yeah it's based off
of like the theme with last year's
haunted and the scavenger hunt that we
did in January what's interesting
because the scavenger hunt focus all
around downtown LA to get like clues and
info and there's this underlying story
line of like these kind of like morning
actions the the enola foundation and
this other group and it's like each one
was telling you that the other one was
lying was lying and you know there was
this promise of some kind of
enlightenment or some kind of like you
know transcendent experience at the end
of it that was all very vague but then
it was turned rats ago that there's no
such thing and it was like very creepy
to have that experience of like bouncing
around the city after hours having
different people tell you that the
person you just left from and just got
directions from this like leading you
astray that you are supposed to go some
other direction yeah and so you know to
be you're almost you know you're in
you're actively in a little story line
yeah you know and it was it was cool cuz
and i also just made me realize how much
there is the city but you know is all it
was all sort of creepy and strain and
you know it seemed like the the the
pieces of that storyline kind of came
together I'd haphazardly but like you
know they were asked to do something at
scare away and they sort of put
something together and then there was at
least one more event at least from what
I've heard and then there was the main
show and then the scavenger hunt kind of
came together to sort of wrap that up
and now this year with unweave the
rainbow which is their new show their
new show it's called yes on weed the
rainbow and it's in four parts in each
one's named after part of the process of
what happens when white encounters an
object so this so it's going on there
was a June show that we just did their
dark in July they're coming back first
getaway for in August show there's going
to be a September show on an October
show yeah and their names respectively
diffusion reflection refraction
reflection and absorption and we just
want to be differences went through
diffuse part more yeah of the event yeah
this was like a little old like like God
would be does it just in a little black
box theater yeah it was like all of like
this little like this little Playhouse
is a little
well that's the thing too is there all
site-specific you know it's it's all
dependent up sort of which building they
can get you know for how long and I
don't know their plan obviously but I
feel like they're kind of going to ramp
up with each consecutive index as
they're suing them yeah the index of
diffusion index of refraction index of
reflection and they're good at kind of
playing with their gonna fling with
alone and togetherness because it's like
in the one I went to we kind of thought
we were going in together I mean we all
knew like it was like you're gonna be
alone then pretty soon yes we were alone
pretty quickly in a pretty unsettling
way this time was like they they found
yet another way to kind of divide us
apart bring us together divide us apart
bring us together yeah exactly it's what
the term of diffusion because one is
when they were describing diffuse and in
their literature they're saying you know
they're talking about the way in which
ideas permeate through a group of people
yeah is what the literature is talking
about that was interesting was like and
it also ties back to the whole thing of
like this this episode of the rainbow
saga and took place in a playhouse first
thing that happens is we all group up
outside everyone that was during our
show time we get pulled in randomly by
the via attendees who are all in black
and just are placed in seemingly random
but seemingly order chair so you're
nowhere near the people that you came in
with and you're sitting in the theater
seats and the lights are extremely dim
it's practically pitch black in there
and then these people come out and they
on the stage and they do a scene from
the crew the bar of the crucible and the
crucible for anyone who does know is of
playing the 50s that was really about
McCarthyism but it's taking the idea of
McCarthyism in and it takes place during
the Salem witch trials so think commies
yeah so it's like you know this whole
thing of mass hysteria and of like a
delusional hunt for enemies within your
own ranks and like not trusting the
people that you're with and you know
just kind of like
lies spreading throughout it and they're
doing this this scene from The Crucible
that's basically like the actor break
the scene words like the lie of like
seeing witches starts you know seeing
simkin sandal yeah cv Wilkin sort
literally with the devil like the
virgins and when that scene is going on
their attendance and then when the scene
ends the actors of the scene are pulling
people randomly off the stage of 18 and
go under this table and just crawl
through the road now in the cnn's during
the CI journey the scene during the
scene attendants are pulling you in and
then with the scene ends the actors join
in on grabbing people too oh well yeah
it's like oh you went way over here yeah
you got pulled up early and I got pull
food like after the seamless concluded
and the actors like God grab the
remaining people and they make you crawl
under this table and then you're like
this bleep are like backstage gap and
you in pitch darkness you kind of have
to find your way forward to spike that
absolutely excuse me the absolute most
minimal amount of light yeah and from
there but there it gets interesting yeah
you you sort of traverse these just the
bowels of this theater and and the
surrounding area and in a sense you know
encountering these different scenarios
some of which you are alone for and
others of which you're thrown to a group
out of nowhere it's aren't you a groom
and what I thought was kind of cool this
time is like it's like they seem like to
really be able to use their space and
then you know they get clever with how
to use like this time it seemed like the
used people they used us against each
other in a sense because like any
specific instances in the in the
duration of the hot it's also like time
out using space they made what's
probably from the outsides is clearly a
small building and they made this like
little this little like Repertory
Theater really labyrinthine oh yeah I
mean and you know you really got the
sense that you are using pretty much all
of you know the various wings and
corridors and dressing rooms and stuff
like they do they really do use
everything and it's like it but
he would happen on to these scenarios in
which as you're passing through you
don't feel like you know I mean I could
not translate in my head the path I took
through that hole that whole maze to how
the the actual workings of that theater
would actually be like and just felt
like I was going through these weird
tunnels and just popping into these
these arbitrary places yeah exactly and
there's so much there's so much that's
sort of disorienting and they do like
then you turn you around and put you
places they take you outside of the
building then put you back into it and
we respond yeah yeah go upstairs and
down sirs and you can't quite tell where
any of those stairs are yeah and and you
know it was like i went into one room
and it was it was neat because it's like
I happened on a bunch of people and my
first instinct was like I don't know how
many of these people are I know a lot of
us are here but I don't know if these
are all actors if none of these are
actors you know like what should i do
like you know it was cool to kind of
have that and this was I mean cuz my
first experience with the loan was going
to that scavenger hunt where I was like
there were moments what it felt like
oddly enough to just the duration of
that scavenger hunt like something was
kind of something about myself was kind
of being revealed to me in a weird way
yeah well that's that's sort of like
what I guess it's kind of what they're
going for it's like they do want to play
off of your emotions and have you you
know it's like have you have like a
sudden like emotional reaction to stuff
and kind of understand what that what
that means like a regular halloween
haunt you get scared or you don't get
scared and all that's really gonna tell
you is like oh I was caught off guard or
not or you know my tolerance for sudden
loud noises I was startled or not or you
know how much I'm affected by the
theatricality of this place or not
where's with alone it's like you kind of
like taken out of your element and
you're suddenly like revealed with how
well can you try well can you test his
trust a stranger out of nowhere you know
how like what is like sudden like what
is physical contact that kind of forced
intimacy do to you well that's what's
cool is because like you know I mean
coming from a more carnival haunting
background it's like
I liked that night and I understand what
it's for but this is neat because it's
like in that environment in a car Mohan
environments like you kind of you accept
the rules and then you sort of walk
through you don't touch anything and you
sort of you only challenge so you're
only sort of walking through so much of
it whereas something like this is like
you get out what you put into it yeah so
it's like there's going to be a certain
amount of bare minimum interaction
regardless but given certain scenarios
how much you choose to let go and just
you know submits them or engage with
them you know that determines where your
head's gonna go or what you're going to
get out of the experience and I think
that's really cool you know because it
depends on where your mind takes you and
what you allow yourself to be
comfortable with new you know because
it's highly interactive that way I mean
like there is there's a fixed route you
know and they're obviously there's
etiquette but you know in certain
scenarios like the others there was one
room in the last front they did which
was like you were crawling through this
giant pillow fort on us it was like it
looked like someone at hummus sheet you
know and there were a bunch of stuffed
animals and you were sort of crawling in
it and then won it like a mass of them
starts to move and from underneath them
just comes this sort of amorphous fuzz
things this sort of stuffy fuzzy thing
and it sort of crawls towards you and
starts to you know like nuzzle you and
stuff like that is very strange but you
know it's like I heard different
accounts of what people would do in that
room you know and like itches well one
one of one of our friends like actually
cuddled up with it and just you know
like look is anything that very
vulnerable and just sort of cuddled up
with it it was like an actor in like
this very elaborate suit that turns into
just this weird stuffed animal shape
thing yeah exactly but you know it's
like I was a little more on guard at
that point you know sort of looking
around yeah and he was more just like
we're cuddling and it just it just kind
of opens you up in waves you know and
then again it's like there are certain
rooms that are about you know how much
will you trust or how much will you
engage like if somebody comes
up to you in this weird demented
scenario and wants to dance with you
what do you do with that you know
usually if there stranger maybe I and
various other things but but yeah like
those are some of it there was
interacting there are some weird
highlights in there like go at one point
everyone gets into this dressing room
that's constantly got a strobe going
yeah and what when you before you get
into that room you're instructed to go
into this room take the clothing off the
walls dress people up in the clothing
and then undress them and then dress
them again with different clothing and
that's basically the instructions are
given and so when you get into this one
when you get into this room there's a
constant strobe flashing people are
standing around or walking around there
are all these costumes it's all these
weird like bits of clothes and like
streamers and tassels and stuff and
pants and shirts that they want you to
put on people and when I went in the guy
who runs the room who was like this this
dude this like kind of like flashy red
jacket that in a cane holding a cane
that was like kind of smiley and kind of
awkward acting and kind of like demented
and mad hattery like say welcome to my
party into my pocket yeah it was ah it
was like perusing the room just kind of
like being like foppish and amused with
the puppy muse but I'm used with people
him and he was like he he was like
wide-eyed and just going through this
room and and he had directed somebody to
play on the piano but the piano was kind
of janky and like a melodic so it's like
a flashing light this sound of like a
detuned pianos falling down stairs and
just people putting a like someone put a
uniqlo shirt on me I think it was cuz we
very stretchy and space fabric II
feeling yeah I ended up in like this and
then like an end jacket with like people
were tying ribbons there were a lot of
these like these ribbon things people
are tying on each other and stuff like
that i put a dude in the skirt like and
then and the thing is you get ganked and
put in that room and then you get taken
out of that room and use this like a
grabber claw by another actor to gank
people even back into that room before
you're set on your way
interesting see I was just yanked back
out again yeah I was just apprehended
and pushed back into the darkened the
void of the hallway yeah before I was
thrown back to the hallway I was used as
a gripper claw to pull more people into
that dressing room yeah and so I was
weird because like kid was I pulled by
another just visitor that was turned
into a grabber you never know that's the
cool thing is it seems like everyone has
a slightly different experience you know
sometimes they'll take your hand and if
you're in a room was with other people
sometimes they'll take your hand and
sort of place it on somebody else's you
know sometimes they won't sometimes you
know it's like the way every actor sort
of interprets you is also different yeah
and then there were certain things that
were very sensory we don't learn from
the strobe light there was it there was
a bit where they put this white sheet
over our heads and laid us down and
there was this like later blade you
download a bundle of cloth and like the
red green and blue flashing lights that
you were looking at through this this mm
not it wasn't like a gauzy er
transparent she was pretty mad like
those light was still flashing through
pretty clearly well that was trippy like
I actually kind of succumbed to that and
just sort of started to not trip in full
but just kind of trip with the play of
the lights and the yeah you know that
they have like this disk or noise rock
playing oh yeah there's always
discordant noise and it comes to alone
yeah there's always you know it's a very
source I assume whoever's doing the
music for the Haunter and I think the
music is done by like the main creators
I serve the big swans fans yeah yeah bro
feels like you know it's there's there's
that there's that element it's like it's
it's very surreal and very dissonant but
also kind of beautiful and kind of you
know mystical you know it's just a
completely different side of the
quote-unquote haunt industry you know
and it's just so nice to have that and
then there was the dance party room oh
yeah there was it there was a room with
a DJ yeah there was a DJ and a guy on
the guitar there was a guy in a guitar I
saw a dude playing a guitar no I don't
know if like Caesar no I don't know if
it was just like you know in the room
with the
words like it was like a another guess
or another entered and saw just sitting
there decide to start playing it was he
by the DJ yeah was standing by the DJ
buddy behind the deck no he was in front
of it it was College so it's like I
think I dude came by either there was an
afternoon there for a bit playing the
guitar or a Duke came by I saw the
guitar and started playing it of his own
volition or he was directed to it samrin
like I was instructed on and i guess
some people did it I was just start to
done by a person to buy recording to you
know find masks find the unmasked people
place the mask on their on their face
and you know like I didn't even hear
that I couldn't make that out that a
room yeah this wasn't the dance program
this was the wardrobe room that you put
masked about people yeah it was in the
dance party because they said you will
come into a room with a big table and
something you know lots of people really
what room did you hear these directions
they put me in a closet for a while no
one it's right after I they put the
sheet on my head the name guided me
through though put me in a closet told
me to wait there and there was like a
looping recording of what at first it's
like it fades into your mind it's like
it first just like where am i and is
someone gonna grab me and then after a
while you start to to sort of pick up
just on what the thing is saying huh and
so I was like interesting I must have
not been put in that closet because I
don't remember getting those
instructions I know it seems like
everyone's experience very lightly at
yeah that's another thing because like
that you can appreciate about loans like
even if you're going into and out of
groups of people you do still feel like
this is really getting to you and
targeting you yeah it's like even if
there are other people around you don't
feel it's not nothing it's like when you
go through a haunted house at the theme
park you feel safe it's got your friend
with you here but this is like they they
explore these concepts of aloneness and
togetherness but you always feel like an
individual yeah no matter where you are
you never feel like you quite have a
group or an ally because somebody can
can focus specifically on you at any
moment and you know inevitably you are
grabbed and directed you know
independent of everybody and so you're
next
even if someone like targets you they're
targeting you because it's like you know
you just happen to be that person that
passes by them in the line at that point
whereas on this is like everyone this is
what you paid for everyone is an
individual there they are targeting we
comin at ya comin at you comin atcha
live and direct yeah from the dark